everyone thinks their data is worth a
lot and it really isn't individual data
is worth exceptionally little almost
nothing it's meaningless Your Health
Data My Health Data doesn't matter take
your health data my health data and add
it to 10 million other people over the
last decade now we're in business now
it's really interesting of course if the
2010s was the era of if the service is
free then you're the product the 2020s
has a new shade on that which is if the
service is free then you're the training
data so the entities that agglomerate
the data have something very special but
every single individual who thinks that
they have a Rembrandt in the Attic of
their hemoglobin levels when they were
in the hospital are going to be out of
luck
that's great